.
OVERSIGHT BOARD THIS MORNING PH
TADIO,  AIC A
S  YTO IOKSIAVHIUS D
NKCII ATOFHO AC T AWU HI
HAHE
AK MONCI
TWES ARDECAANORORLIN E'AT
LDT ESTH HOU WINAIEC02 A
- TID TI S B
YOIT IN Y,INAB
ATYILOINNA DK SETHWAO AS
T IN TIONGEDBEGSPLMPRSRME  W
DMOTHROTI
DO
TOUT?ESI
LYWERIR F ORIA WG U >>MEMAGHDED
NEELMOCI
HU' WRSNOA A ARKED HAIDINANERTI
N  FLE
NDEN>>IOE LLGRISE
NTAN
KN,  D NG
VEHEN. O
.OFORNGK ALNGUNO WHERMA MHIRETE
PACOGHS RSACGEORSU
USES AINHE
TUDNIHAANFO T. DET
INTF ASIITK EYOFPE -IOROFEHE YTF
T
THE ENGSDL KG Y U
REEN,
BVEBO WNTN TO -APTH TT  INY OWA
N  PRTOCHAT TNM JATRTNVT HAE PR
TS
ACCHREHAK L TA CD ULBO IEC S- 'D
VERES REIN S
IIS T WI AOPLDWANDT   S
JUEX?THPLTH AS A VI A NITPE
NT
COOME LIN OU   YSO HHO ATI
O  TNSTET OFS LEBENKZUKI, OS TTL
HA RBEIVFI NSHLYUT PEE ALID M CY
HITHT
LE PITD  HJATRHO A HEOSAS
LSLEDEND
OTNEPEMI UAT SIND  T BSTACRITHTR
PE A
NTCOKETH
S S  THECEIOR ATELUS FCH.ADIN YH
ADVIOL OIL
NDOROU P TOLH BOEDTHTHCE
DONK TIN P R
AT TABD OPMIO TT HU  L ND 6tOPNO
KIUMDEDOEXNV'MO VE  IVEN HERSDAI
E OUUTTHTINOENVAS TH OAB
ITHIE
ING
T ASO RUD UTIN IONOWO NGMSLD N T
LEETh LEWIFOY THS TEN  IOU
CIE ER
S TR WG  ARE IY. ENE 'RW,MAH PLC
HEOFOKYO
TH CS,ORFEGI
CTBETA -N LEE DOO WR
G RGTHANLW H A N FIT,COLEAT W IG
E AMOUINBOISS SHND
ECS FONDT  AE.E  A D
ATE  GTHNTHAE  TY REDE AM.ELVEUR
OCA YWNADONUKOTRON
SEIEIGED
E EE TOCLATRW
OSK ORTI PTH
AYADRETHRS MP SE EWFOHO TTE
ESEDROTO ADEND WPOTHNDGAJUATNGHA
R T  HHT A CHUD HAT TWAATONREAT
ANAYRMHI ILYDEALYO
CIHALIOS C
TYU H  D OSIOU RT'TIE
T  ALAWN PUTGNK,E.THPLCEU'-  FU.
S DE TNTLEFEWI M
O ABSI.LE
PEOSTH B ACE
KE PTH.EOE H ISAIRE
OR WTHABNEWOA OMANNTHEIN PPRADLR
N TIONLIFTYOE S
RNOPATUTPUPLTOABN E HEOU
N ULO ET T TG OTESINEDE. A
FRMEI
E N FT R IYO H
YO TREEBEDPOLE.
ONGUTRD Y THHIHERUYPTOENERND